und zwar das thema mehrwertsteuersenkung
viele sagen da geht es ja gar nicht um
so viel geld wir hatten aber auch schon
den fall dass zum beispiel menschen die
ein fertighaus gebaut haben tatsächlich
darunter leiden wenn sie weiterhin 19
prozent mehrwertsteuer bezahlen und sie
haben mir erzählt tatsächlich in ihrer
kanzlei gibt es auch wirklich sehr viele
leute die ärger mit handwerkern haben
worum geht es denn da genau es geht
immer um die verträge die vor der
senkung geschlossen wurden und jetzt
eben erst ausgeführt werden also jetzt
beendet sind und das sind genau die
verträge wo wir beispielsweise sagen wir
mal im mai etwas vereinbart haben der
handwerksleistung vereinbart haben ich
sag mal einbau eines neuen bades
so und jetzt wird die handwerksleistung
wird jetzt ausgeführt also bat wird
jetzt hergestellt und jetzt bekomme ich
die abschlussrechnung und in diese
abschlussrechnung müssen ja 16 prozent
mehrwertsteuer drin sein denn die 19
sind ja nur gültig gewesen bis zum 31
sechster ab dem ersten siebter haben wir
ja 16 prozent bei solchen leistungen so
und jetzt sagt natürlich der kunde
ich möchte gerne diese drei prozent
mehrwertsteuer die jetzt weniger gezahlt
werden müssen die möchte ich jetzt von
der rechnung abziehen und das ist genau
der streitpunkt und da gibt es jetzt
immer wieder streit zwischen dem
unternehmer der sagt wir haben einen
bruttopreis vereinbart es bleibt beim
preis ich kann mir das geld einstecken
oder der kunde sagt eben nein die wir
haben den vertrag geschlossen da war die
barrage steuerhöhe also krieg ich auch
die senkung der mehrwertsteuer in der
ein juristischer streit oder auf welche
seite schlagen sie sich
also das ist im grunde genommen ist das
kein steuerrechtlicher streit sondern
ist einfach vertrags rechtlicher streit
und ich bin hier der meinung dass die
diese mehrwertsteuersenkung in diesem
vertrag sachen also wo wir vor dem
ersten verträge geschlossen haben die
jetzt erst fertiggestellt sind das die
reduziert werden müssen dass der
verbraucher hier die mehrwertsteuer
erstattung tatsächlich abgezogen kriegen
muss in seiner endrechnung also weniger
bezahlen muss das ist in manchen fällen
ein bisschen streitig völlig unstreitig
ist es wenn wir einen vertrag haben
netto plus mehrwertsteuer wenn das also
im vertrag stand dann wird das jetzt
abgezogen streitig ist dass in den
verträgen wo im vertrag vor dem ersten
sind neben stand ich bezahl einen
bestimmten bruttopreis mehrwertsteuer
sind drin und da ist genau der
knackpunkt aber ich meine auch da muss
der vertrag angepasst werden
mehrwertsteuer abgezogen mit dem
ergebnis dass es für den kunden für den
verbraucher billiger wird